There's someone who works in our building here...
...who has a disability, who's been with us 16 years.
His name is Kenny and I take Kenny out to lunch about two, three times a year...
...and whenever I walk back after that lunch, that day is very different for me.
I find myself taking a step back and really appreciating all that we have...
...and also valuing the company in a way because of the way in which we've opened the doors for Kenny,...
...and I think brought him something in his life that he probably won't have had.
And also, I'm amazed how many people celebrate Kenny in this building...
...whether it's his birthday, his anniversary.
People know his family, his coach.
It's added a dimension to the company...
...in a way that I can't properly explain, but it's made us better people.